it's been 22 years since the events of
the first movie and that means anyone
younger than 22 in a world that we're
creating has never lived in a world
where dinosaurs didn't exist they're
coming into this with this idea that
dinosaurs are not really that
fascinating corporate felt genetic
modification would up the wow factor
they're dinosaurs Wow enough and so what
does jurassic world need to do to build
a bigger intendant's they need to make
it bigger faster more scary that was
awesome the character that I play Clara
she runs the park and she's someone
who's very disconnected from her own
humanity because in the quest for profit
she makes some disastrous mistakes we
just went and made a new dinosaur I me
not a good idea we shot this movie for
imax and so our aspect ratio is the
native ratio of all the digital IMAX
screens in the world so when you see our
film the whole thing takes up the entire
screen it's a pretty stunning experience
you really do feel the difference you
got 20,000 people you got no more votes
you don't have enough guns there's so
many sequences in this that I'm excited
to see especially in imax the Moses or
the underwater stuff the Raptor
motorcycle sequence I think that's
coming pretty great if we do this we do
this my way basically everything it's
just such a iconic franchise and there's
so many people that love it so much so
it's been quite the honor to be a part
of it we're talking about an animal here
highly intelligent animal it's crazy
like there were so many moments on set
we're all of us felt like we're all kids
in our backyard making a dinosaur movie
like this is such a wish fulfillment for
someone who saw the original film it was
just an enormous blasts
you